[Music]
miley rallied free britney fans at her
vegas concert sunday ahead of news of a
major twist
britney's conservatorship attorney sam
ingham is expected to resign
the lawyer came under fire after
britney's testimony and in this new
yorker investigation co-written by
pulitzer prize-winning journalist ronan
farrow
we talked to multiple sources around and
close to this conservatorship
who felt that sam ingham britney
spears's court-appointed lawyer
is loyal to jaime and the
conservatorship
first and britney second that's not all
britney's longtime manager larry rudolph
also reportedly resigned on monday
claiming britney's quote
intention to officially retire i started
off as brittany's
lawyer i put together her demos for her
larry who said it's been two and a half
years since he communicated with
brittany
told us back in 2013 how he helped her
get her first record deal
we do have a unique relationship and it
goes back to when she was 13 years old
you know i mean she was a kid when i met
her there's a trust factor between the
two of us
i know what she's thinking she knows
what i'm thinking amidst this shakeup
et has learned britney's personal
conservator jody montgomery isn't going
anywhere
in fact jody's attorney tells et that
just yesterday
brittany asked her to stay on in the
role another startling claim from that
new yorker investigation
brittany called 9-1-1 to report herself
as a victim of conservatorship
abuse but accords with what we learned
in her testimony the next day which is
she really did
describe this in terms of criminal abuse
so what does britney's mom think of all
the conservatorship drama
lynn spears reportedly says she has
mixed feelings about everything and
quote
it's a lot of pain a lot of worry
you